Okay.
So before Dan gets carried away
with databases,
let's look at what happens
when you use an intent
to transition between activities.
Within Sunshine,
if you tap on a list in the main activity
it opens up the detail activity.
But the main activity
remains on the backstack,
ready to reappear as soon
as you hit Back.
Now, in that example,
both activities are within the same app.
But as we learned in lesson three,
you can also watch the browser
or Maps app from Sunshine.
Or for that matter,
the user can hit Home.
And launch apps from there,
or they can use the Recent key
or switch to another app
using Notifications.
All of these options mean you can end up
with a lot of apps on your backstack.
Now, keep in mind that our resources
on devices are extremely limited.
So it's not a good idea to have dozens
of apps sitting idle in the background.
Android solves this for us,
so you don't have to use
those awful task killer apps.
So, how does it do that?
Well, it kills low priority applications
that you haven't used in a while.
We'll go into detail on exactly how
it figures out which app needs to die
in lesson six.
But for now, it's important to realize
that your app isn't in control
of its own destiny.
It can be killed at any time.
So you need to know
how to deal with that.
And that means understanding
the lifecycle of an activity
and the signals we get from the framework
to indicate its progress
through the lifetime.